i'm an independent travel agent and from
january to june this year
we have had two people travel abroad i'm
a netherland pilot
i haven't flown for over a year i run a
schools travel company
and we haven't taken a trip aboard since
february 2020.
we're in debt we need help from the
government
after 16 months stopped in its tracks
the travel industry came to westminster
to demand the government loosen
restrictions in time for summer
they said there'd be a risk-based
approach they said that things would
open up
when the scientific evidence allowed it
it does why we stopped from flying from
places where the
viral rate is lower than the uk that
makes no sense
for travel agents who don't get paid
until people go on holiday
time is running out every time they
mention travel it's
aviation and about all this money
they've given to aviation
and travel agents have not seen any of
it and we
are like the engines of the business
we're putting the seats on the planes
and we need the help there were protests
in belfast and edinburgh ii urging
ministers reviewing measures this week
to extend the green list of destinations
that don't require quarantine on return
and remove it all together for those
who've had two doses of vaccine
i'm waiting to hear from the scientists
if you like the the experts the joint
biosecurity
center will follow their advice as to
how
and where and when it's safe to open up
and also of course listening to them
about
what it means if you've been double
vaccinated and what that could mean to
changes in the protocols the people
protesting here
are adamant the government needs to take
action now not just to save summer
but to protect the viability many of
these businesses and there is
anger too at the decision to wave
quarantine rules
vips and some fans attending the finals
of euro 2020 officials and sponsors will
only be allowed to leave their hotels to
attend
the games at wembley but mps on all
sides condemned the move
we can't have any elite any elite of any
kind
being allowed to be exempted from rules
which are crippling others
millions of jobs are being sacrificed
and we can't even have the hope
of a summer holiday it's one rule for
them and another rule for the rest of us
ministers will reveal any changes to
restrictions in the coming days
if the industry doesn't get back in the
air soon some
may be grounded permanently paul kelso
sky news